[Music]
thank you
in Phila K Dick's novel The Man in the
High Castle if we're looking for a
traditional kind of hero I think the
person the character that we would say
comes closest to that is Juliana Frank
for several reasons and we can talk
about her being a hero in terms of the
plot saving the day in a certain way as
we'll talk about in just a bit but also
in a certain sense as well a
metaphysical hero realizing something
drastically important both through
contemplation and through action about
the very nature of the world that
they're in which we'll talk about
elsewhere I think there's a great
Revelation that happens in the very
final chapter and so we meet her
originally
in the Rocky Mountain States which she's
moved to to get away from the Pacific
States of America she has become a judo
instructor and so the first scene that
we actually Glimpse her in she is
um you know getting ready to take a
shower for months she'd been living here
in Carson City Colorado she was a judo
instructor her work day had ended She
Was preparing to take a shower she felt
tired all the showers were in use by
customers of Ray's gym so she'd been
standing waiting outside in the coolness
enjoying the smell of Mountain Air the
quiet and she you know goes on there and
then we we learn some things about her
right I learned this from the Japanese
and by Placid attitude towards mortality
along with money making Judo how to kill
how to die Yang and Yin but that's
behind now this is Prada distant land
the you know Christian land you could
say and
um she's talking with one of the
customers Miss Davis who says
um you know you know Miss Frank I've
gotten so much out of Judo even more out
of Zen I wanted to tell you and then she
asks uh Juliana
did they hurt you much and she says who
the Japanese before you learn to defend
yourself and Juliana says it was
Dreadful you've never been out there on
the coast where they are it could happen
here Juliana said they might decide to
occupy this region too and then Juliana
says you never know what they're going
to do they hide their real thoughts and
Miss Davis says what did they make you
do
and Juliana says everything and uh Miss
Davis says oh God I'd fight and then
Juliana walks away so what are we
learning from this that while she lived
in the Pacific States of America she was
raped by the Japanese
um it didn't turn her off from learning
Judo which now she has as her livelihood
and we're also going to learn about her
from her ex-husband so there's a passage
yet earlier in chapter one the very end
of it where Frank Frank is missing his
ex-wife and asking the Oracle will I
ever see her again
so we get this great description
Juliana the best looking woman he'd ever
married soot black eyebrows and hair
Trace Amounts of Spanish blood
distributed as Pure Color even to her
lips her rubbery soundless walk she'd
worn saddle shoes left over from high
school in fact all her clothes headed
dilapidated quality and the definite
suggestion of being old and often washed
he and she had been broke so long that
despite her look she had to wear a
cotton sweater cloth zipper jacket Brown
Tweed skirt and Bobby Socks and she
hated him in it because it made her look
she'd said like a woman who played
tennis or collected mushrooms in the
woods but above and beyond everything he
had originally been drawn by her
screwball expression for no reason
Juliana greeted strangers with a
portentious noodnik Mona Lisa smile that
hung them up between responses whether
to say hello or not and she was so
attractive that more often than not they
did say hello whereupon Juliana just
glided by and uh Frank we're getting her
through Frank's eyes at first he thought
it was just bad playing eyesight but
finally he decided it revealed a deep
dyed otherwise concealed stupidity at
her core which you know that's rather
debatable it might just be his point of
view and then a little bit later on in
the work we get uh some thoughts on
Frank's part again when he's trying to
sell the the jewelry and he thinks oh
man you know if only we had Juliana here
then
um you know we could have her sell this
she we could take pictures she could go
in and demonstrate it and then there's
some very interesting speculations
he thinks I I know she's living with
some guy sleeping with him as if she was
his wife I know Juliana she couldn't
survive any other way I know how she
gets around Nightfall when it gets cold
and dark and everybody's home sitting a
lot around the living room she was never
made for a solitary life maybe the guy's
a real nice guy some shy student she
picked up she'd be a good woman for some
young guy who never had the courage to
approach a woman before she's not hard
or cynical it would do him a lot of good
I hope to hell she's not with some older
guy that's what I couldn't stand some
experienced mean guy with a toothpick
sticking outside out of the mouth side
of his mouth pushing her around and then
you know he's he's thinking I was too
rough for her and I'm not so bad there's
a hell of a lot of guys worse than me I
could pretty much well figure out what
she was thinking what she wanted when
she felt lonely or bad or depressed I
spent a lot of time worrying and fussing
over her but it wasn't enough she
deserves she deserved more she deserves
a lot he thought so we're getting a
sketch uh could be you know accurate
could not and this is a great segue into
her hooking up with Joe this uh at least
on the surface an Italian truck driver
and
um
we get this uh interesting encounter
that's uh taking place between the two
of them they actually uh go home
together and
um you know she's she goes out and does
some grocery shopping comes back and
he's still sleeping in bed and she
thinks oh the truck's gone did he miss
it obviously did he intend to miss it
that's what I wonder and then we get
this interesting speculation What A
peculiar man he'd been so active with
her going on almost all night and yet
it had been as if he were not actually
there doing it but never being aware
thoughts on something else perhaps and
then she's using more and she thinks
maybe he's done it so much it's second
nature his body makes the motion like
mine now as I put these plates in silver
in the back and she wakes him up and
they have some uh talking back and forth
and he's she's asking him about this
tattoo and he says oh that's from Cairo
where this great battle had taken place
so his his past is part of what they're
narrating as we go on as we're going to
find out his past is
partly what he presents to her but it's
also untrue in other aspects and then he
introduces her to this book The
Grasshopper lies heavy not in the sense
of she didn't have any idea of what it
is but she hadn't read it and he's
talking about it and they have a lot of
back and forth discussions that we've
already discussed elsewhere about what's
in the book the point is he wants to get
her involved in discussion and thinking
about these matters of an alternate
history so that he can get her into a
sort of plot and what we're going to
find
is something quite
interesting going on an observation
on her part
and
we see her saying to herself
I wish I had never let him come with me
now it's too late I know I can't get rid
of him he's too strong something
terrible is happening she thought coming
out of him and I seem to be helping it
and then there's a moment of
maybe even like tenderness between them
what's the matter he uh says to her a
mood your problem I'll analyze you free
you're scared of men right and she says
I don't know and he says it was possible
to tell us not only because I took
special care to notice your wants and
she says because you've gone to bed with
so many girls that's what you started to
say and he says but I know I'm right
listen I'll never hurt you Juliana on my
mother's body I give you my word I'll be
specially considerate and if you want to
make an issue out of my experience I'll
give you the advantage of that you'll
lose your Jitters I can relax you and
improve you in not much time either
you've just had bad luck
she not had cheered a bit but she still
felt cold and sad
and she didn't know why so she's got a
kind of sense about this guy who's now
her lover and they decide they're going
to take off and drive to Denver the big
city and enjoy themselves together for a
bit he's got a nice supply of money and
what we find out happening
it's interesting too because it's going
to come up in the form of letting
Juliana think that it's her idea
so
um they talk about the book again they
drive on quite a bit and then
um Joe says you take to that grasshopper
book so much I wondered do you suppose a
man who writes a bestseller an author
like that Adam said do people write
letters to him I bet lots of people
praise his book by letters to him maybe
even visit
all at once she understood
Joe it's only another 100 miles his eyes
Shone he smiled at her happy again no
longer flushed or troubled we could she
said you drive so good it'd be nothing
to go on up there would it
slowly Joe said well I doubt a famous
man lets visitors drop in probably so
many of them why not try Joe she grabbed
his shoulder squeezed him excitedly all
he could do is send us away please
with great deliberation Joe said when
we've gone shopping and got new clothes
all spruced up that's important to make
a good impression maybe even rent a new
car up in Cheyenne but you can do that
and so now they've actually got like a
plan going they're going to go to Denver
get themselves checked into the hotel
get some new clothes get haircuts and
then actually go and drive another 100
miles to Cheyenne nearby to Cheyenne and
uh meet the author abenson for Juliana
not for Joe but you know a way of him
humoring her
so they do go shopping and Dick actually
describes in considerable detail Through
The Eyes of Juliana what it is that
they're getting and she's quite
interested in this but there's another
really important
feature to this that I want to bring up
that comes up several times in here so
she thinks to herself
um she tells him I hope we have fun in
Denver you need to relax I want you to
and she thinks if you don't you're going
to fly apart in a million pieces like a
bursting spring what happens to me then
how do I get back and do I just leave
you I want the good time you promised me
she thought I don't want to be cheated
I've been cheated too much in my life
before by too many people which would
include even her husband Frank right and
so as they're deciding uh what to do and
doing the shopping she says let's eat
dinner uh well he says let's eat dinner
and then she says oh I we need to get a
little bit of new stuff pajamas and uh
Juliana says we'll go and register at
the hotel we'll change we'll eat and
then she thinks to herself it better be
a really fine hotel or it's all off even
this late we'll ask them at the hotel
what's the best place in Denver to eat
and the name of a good nightclub where
we can see a once in a lifetime act not
some local talent but some big names
from Europe and she keeps looking at Joe
who has changed his hair he's dyed it
blonde or actually perhaps it already
was blonde and she's thinking with his
hair short and blonde in his new clothes
he doesn't look like the same person do
I like him better this way it was hard
to tell so they check in
and then Joe it decides for them that
they're actually not going to stay in
Denver she says are we going to stay one
day or two do you think we could stay
three and he says we're going on tonight
going on to Cheyenne to meet up with
Robinson
At first she did not understand when she
did she could not believe him
he says after we eat
so wear that blue dress that costs so
much the one you like the really good
one and she says it's too late tonight
and she says no no we'll be through
dinner around 5 30 6 at the latest we
can get up to Cheyenne in two two and a
half hours that's only 8 30 say 9 at the
latest tears began to Surge up into her
eyes and she found herself doubling up
her fists with the thumbs inside as
she'd done as a child she felt her jaw
wobble and when she spoke her voice
could hardly be heard I don't want to go
and see him tonight I'm not going I
don't want to at all even tomorrow I
just want to see the sights here like
you promised me and as she spoke The
Dread once more reappeared and settled
on her chest The Peculiar blind panic
that had scarcely gone away even in the
brightest of moments with him it Rose to
the top and commanded her she felt it
quivering in her face shining out so
that he could easily take note of it and
Joe actually tells her put on the dress
or I'll kill you
closing her eyes she began to giggle my
training she thought it was true after
all now we'll see can he kill me or
can't I pinch a nerve in his back and
him for life I know maybe you
can throw me Joe said or maybe not not
throw you she said maim you permanently
I actually can I lived out on the west
coast the Japs taught me up in Seattle
you go on to Cheyenne if you want to and
leave me here don't try to force me I'm
scared of you and I'll try I'll try to
get you so bad if you come to me right
and then there's this incident
with the shirts
Joe
is been presenting himself as I am just
this you know old uh well not really old
35 year old former Italian uh soldier
who fought in these these wars and then
these uh you know uniformed Boy comes
valet service Joe uh gathers up the new
white shirts carries them to the Bellboy
and says can you get them out in half an
hour just ironing the folds yes I'm sure
they can and Julianna says how did you
know a new white shirt can't be worn
until it's pressed
and he said well you know when I was
younger I used to dress up and go out a
lot and she starts to suspect everything
and she says did you really have your
hair cut and dyed I think your hair
always was blonde and you were wearing a
hair piece and then she says You must be
an SD man you're supposed to come up
here and kill abenson isn't that so I
know it is I guess I'm pretty dumb and
he says well actually you got it I did
fight in North Africa but I was a
Vermont Commando I infiltrated British
headquarters and she says you're not
Italian you're a German Swiss
and so he says we're gonna go up there
and we're going to fulfill this Mission
and she starts to have a breakdown a
anxiety attack and He suggests that
he'll give her some pills that will help
her out and she starts to spiral
so she has a sort of lapse into mental
illness and he actually says oh you are
in fact mentally ill uh you're very sick
we can't go and he says I can't take you
to the abundances maybe we'll we'll go
tomorrow so she goes into the bathroom
and she gets out a razor blade and when
she comes out she cuts them across the
neck severing his keratoid artery and he
has to keep himself Alive by holding
pressure on it and then she goes out
into the corridor naked the hairdresser
says oh you're drunk get back in your
room and then she gets herself dressed
up she puts on her new coat closer new
handmade leather purse picked up her
suitcase and as many of the parcels
which were hers she could manage and she
goes to the car and uh before that so as
you know maybe I can tell them at the
desk that you're dying don't look for me
back at the apartment because I'm not
going back there I'm also taking your
money and what is she going to do well
she's going to go up and warn the
adamsons that the Commandos from the
Nazi regime are actually out there
looking for him so she calls the
abensons and says I've got to come up
and see you it's actually Mrs abinson
who gets the phone she says the Oracle
has told me to come and and see you and
in the meantime she actually finishes
the book and
what we find is that
there's so much more in the book than
Joe understood what is it abenson wanted
to say nothing about his make-believe
world am I the only one who knows I bet
I am nobody else really understands
grasshopper but me they just imagine
that they do no it may seem at that
point that perhaps that's a reflection
of her uh mental derangement Insanity
lapse whatever we want to call it but as
it turns out she is the one who has the
greatest insight into the nature of the
book and even reality and we'll finish
up by you know she does get up there and
warns abenson
um and and uh the abbons are not happy
with her and then Hawthorne abenson says
do you know what you are this girl is a
diamond a little cathonic spirit that
roams tirelessly over the face of the
Earth she's doing what's instinctive to
her simply expressing her being she
didn't mean to show up here and do harm
it simply happened to her just as
whether it happens to us and there's an
important Revelation not just that the
SD people are trying to kill abenson but
something about the nature of reality
itself in their world so this tells us
an awful lot of great interest of about
this character Juliana Frank who again
if there is a hero or heroine to this
she probably has the best claim to be
that particular person